[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL IRISH: Hi, and welcome back
to GDL Presents, wherein
we profile a developer, dive
into a little bit of their
code and theory behind the
process, and find out how
exactly they make the
really incredible
things that they do.
Today we have with us
Hakim El Hattab.
How's it going, Hakim?
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Hey, it's going
really good, thanks.
Thanks for having me.
PAUL IRISH: So Hakim, you are an
interactive developer based
in New York.
You're from Sweden.
You've made a bunch of
really cool labs.
Originally you were a Flash
developer, is that correct?
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Right,
that's right.
I used to work at Fantasy
Interactive.
And worked on a lot of campaign
sites, like heavy on
animation for Nintendo, and
that sort of thing.
A site that links for a short
time, but has the craziest
things you can think of.
Tornadoes just thrown
across the screen,
and all that stuff.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, you're kind of
you're one of this cadre of
Flash to JavaScript developers
that we saw, like, you, Mr.
Dube, Seb Lee-Delisle,
Paul Lewis.
Like this amazing talent when
it comes to visuals and
interactive design, and all
of a sudden, being in the
JavaScript community, we saw
you and these other people
coming in and starting
to do these
really impressive things.
And we're just like,
wow, thank you.
Yes, there's a lot to learn.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: I think that's
really interesting.
Coming from a Flash background,
you have that
animation way of thinking,
like you think about
everything in motion.
And then just as JavaScript was
getting powerful enough to
actually replicate some of the
things, that's where it got
interesting for myself and
a lot of the other names
mentioned as well, I think.
When you could start producing
things that we already did in
Flash, we could do it as
good in JavaScript.
And that's been really
exciting.
And I think just from working
on so many sites with heavy
animations, you get into the
nitty-gritty of using equations.
And that right perfect sensation
in UI should feel
fast here, to these in and out,
or to do, I don't know,
you tweak numbers
indefinitely.
That didn't really exist
in the typical
HTML developer community.
And now it's starting to happen
more and more though,
people are coming in learning
JavaScript and animation at
the same time, just because
they're seeing a lot of good
examples of it.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, absolutely I
think that, in your products
in particular, we've seen a lot
of detail when it comes to
the subtlety of interaction,
that many people hadn't
realized that is worthwhile
to spend time on.
But I've seen a lot of
your experiments.
So I'm actually going to-- let's
bring up one of your
experiments now.
Anyone can go visit these
at lab.hakim.se.
But there's some great
stuff in here.
More recently you've worked on
Avgrund and Meny, which are
pretty cool.
Do you want talk about these?
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Yeah,
absolutely.
So let's start with the names
which I find funny myself.
I've gone for a full transition
into Swedish names
for everything I do.
So I am Swedish originally,
I'm born and raised there.
And Avgrund and Meny
are the two of the
first Swedish names.
Just kind of keep going,
kind of like Ikea.
That's my plan for it.
So Avgrund is a concept for--
well, I think Chris Coyier
expressed it the best way,
it's receding modal.
So it takes the typical pop-up
concept, but it also places
the page backwards in depth
and blurs is out, so you
really get that feeling of
content being de-emphasize and
pop-up being emphasized.
And here in Avgrund you're
using, I guess you're just
throwing a black background
around everything, you're
using a 2D transform to scale
the background, a CSS filter
for the blur.
Is that how you're
doing things?
HAKIM EL HATTAB: That's exactly
it, you got it.
The filter blur is kind of slow,
so I've disabled it when
I've used it myself on
a couple of places.
But it adds a nice effect.
Still, it's just a heavy
operation to bl a
whole page like that.
PAUL IRISH: It's really cool.
And so Meny is a way to kind of
hide a menu but reveal it
in 3D space.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Yeah,
that started out as--
I had an idea for a really
cool concept.
I didn't really think it was
going to be very useful.
But then, after having
built it out and
seeing that it actually--
I mean it added some
value to the page.
Because you could hide a menu,
you could reveal it, without
losing all the contents
on the right side.
So it was a hidden menu that
still kept all the content
visible, even if you
expanded it.
A lot of other menus will expand
on top of the contents,
and you have to hide them to
see the content again.
Plus it just really
looks cool.
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: It totally
looks cool.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Yeah, this is
the latest version where you
can set it on any direction
as a page.
First off, it was just
a concept for
coming in from the left.
And then I revised it, and
open-sourced it, and packaged
it up nicely, so then
anyone could use it.
PAUL IRISH: That's
really nice.
Yeah, this is great.
I've actually--
we profiled Michael Deal earlier
on this program.
And he's already using both of
these experiments in his work.
So I'm seeing a lot of solid
adoption already for some of
these UI concepts.
What kind of inspires
you to explore
these interaction ideas?
HAKIM EL HATTAB: I think that's
what's always inspired
me to work in the field
that I work.
Just interfaces and interaction
has always been
what's exciting to me.
I studied digital animation,
which got me into the Flash
scene, and animation
in general.
Not even just interactively,
but video as well.
And then got into Flash,
and did some very
heavy lifting in animation.
But then, now lately, I'm mostly
interested in building
useful UI components.
Nothing extreme anymore, I
want to go more to useful
utility instead of cosmetics.
That's sort of where
I'm going.
PAUL IRISH: I want to bring up
an experiment right now, which
might fall into the cosmetics
side of things, perhaps.
This is stroll.js.
And so stroll is a small little
library that applies
effects to a list as you
scroll through it.
And so there's a number of
different 2D and 3D effects
that you can experience
as you're scrolling
through a big list.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: There's
been a lot of
contributions as well.
So I only started out with about
eight of them, and then
people start adding to
them like crazy.
So there's a bunch of different
styles on there now,
that I didn't think of myself.
But I built the framework for
it, I guess, and then it was
easy enough to add
other styles.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, and this
was a fun project.
I noticed especially when it was
open sourced, I personally
got really excited.
I hopped in there, I started
viewing the source, and I was
like, I think we could maybe do
this a little bit faster.
And so actually, I'll bring up
now what I did when I saw it
the first time.
Which is, we had recently added
a feature to the Chrome
dev tools where you can
essentially get, more or less,
a rendering profile.
So I'll do that now.
So this is in Timeline
and Frames.
And I'll record a little
session, and
scroll a little bit.
And so what happens is, we're
able to capture a little area.
And then I'm going to narrow
that down, and we can zoom in
to basically see the length
of all the frames.
And in some of these cases, some
of these frames become
quite long.
So the target length of a frame
is 16 milliseconds.
But in some of these cases,
we have frames around 70
milliseconds.
And so sometimes with this tool,
you get a good idea of
exactly what's taking so long.
And in this case, there's a
recalculate style that takes a
full 20 milliseconds.
And we can click over to see
exactly what line in our
script caused the recalc style
to happen, and see.
So what I and a few other
developers did early on was
look at this and identify
where we
could optimize things.
Maybe we could avoid hitting
this particular line of code
on all loops and do it
more infrequently.
But there was, I think--
HAKIM EL HATTAB: And you pulled
it off really well.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
Yeah, and I think lately there's
been a few more tools
recently to get the browser
side prospective of how
exactly things are
happening, right?
So from a developer tools side,
we can get a better idea
of how to improve this work.
Is there anything that--
is there any normal workflows
that you've gone through for
dealing with improving the
runtime performance of your
experiments?
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Oh
yeah, absolutely.
Not only my experiments, but
even my daytime work.
It's all about optimization.
Because now JavaScript and HTML
is being used for more
and more heavy production.
What used to be Flash, these
really heavy interactive
productions, animation
productions, and then when we
do that in HTML, we need the
tools to analyze it and
profile it.
And this is really starting
to pay off.
The tools set is incredibly
good, short of seeing it as my
future editor for code
as well, I can do
everything in there.
I've definitely been using
Timeline as well for some of
my projects, it's been
very helpful.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
Awesome.
So we'll switch over--
HAKIM EL HATTAB: So it might be
worth mentioning though, on
the scroll effects there, that
was also remade into a mobile
experiment.
When Chrome Experiments opened
up for mobile submissions, I
rebuilt it, or did a
V2 on it, that does
support touch events.
And I had to build my own
momentum scrolling.
You know that kind of
feeling you get?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Because
I couldn't use--
there's this overflow scroll
for mobile support,
specifically that does
momentum scrolling
automatically for you.
But I couldn't do that, because
you can't read the
positions of the list
items then while it
scrolls with momentum.
And so I wrote my own.
Anyway, you should
check that out.
It's pretty cool.
It looks cool in iPhone.
PAUL IRISH: Very cool.
And I think that is that at
mobile.chromeexperiments.com?
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Yeah,
that should be it.
Actually, if you just hit
chromeexperiments.com on your
phone, you'll get there.
PAUL IRISH: Ah, true, true.
Yeah, there's a lot of really
powerful experiments there
that are optimized for
the touch experience.
A lot of good stuff.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: That was an
interesting performance change.
PAUL IRISH: An interesting
performance
change, right, yeah.
Dealing with slower hardware,
less memory, a bit of it is
trial and error to find out how
far you can push things.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Right, at the
time I didn't have a good
profiling tool for mobile.
That's starting to get
better as well,
definitely very helpful.
But it was sort of
like a black box.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
Do you use debugging tools
for mobile now?
Or what's your workflow there?
HAKIM EL HATTAB: I just started
using the-- because
they come built in now
to Safari 6.0.
And it's really, really fast.
I've started using that for
the mobile work that I do.
And it's been helpful.
PAUL IRISH: I've personally
experimented with the Safari 6
remote debugging, the Chrome on
Android remote debugging,
and also Adobe Shadow.
It doesn't have all the
capabilities of your typical
web kit inspector, but
it's very convenient.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: I tried
Adobe Shadow as well.
I guess my only complaint there
was the response time is
little bit slow.
Just communication in between.
Maybe it was my set up.
I don't know.
It felt a lot slower.
PAUL IRISH: OK, cool.
I wanted to shift over to a
project that I think a lot of
people have seen.
And that is reveal.js.
So reveal.js is a
slide framework.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: It's a HTML
presentation framework.
PAUL IRISH: I like it.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: That's what
I usually call it.
It's just a presentation
framework built on top of HTML
and using your browser to
create fully fledged
presentations that
you'd typically
create in desktop software.
It's pretty popular space
for HTML right now.
There's a lot of similar
frameworks.
I guess, over time reveal.js has
differentiated itself as a
really feature-rich framework.
It's just happened over time.
We've added many more features
since the original so simple.
But now it has Markdown support,
it has PDF exports,
and themes, and transitions
styles.
You name it, a lot of
things in there.
PAUL IRISH: It's very nice.
Yeah, I've used it a lot.
And actually we had an internal
conference inside
Google a bit ago.
And one of the engineers who
works on Chrome's rendering
path took a look.
We were both sharing a
presentation, and using reveal.js.
And so he actually dove into
some of the techniques that
were being used for reveal.js
and found a few
insufficiencies where you
could actually eek out
slightly better performance.
And I think one of them
was my fault.
I was applying a z-index to
some of the headlines.
And when you apply a z-index, it
actually bumps that render
layer out of the rest
of the render layer.
So let's say we have a slide
and we're transitioning it
with the transform, having a
z-index on one of the elements
inside that, brings it to
another thing, and so that has
to be made manipulated
separately.
And so we were getting overall
a slower FPS number.
And so--
HAKIM EL HATTAB: That's really
interesting because I use 3D
transforms inside of the slides
as well for these hover
effects on my links.
They do a 3D roll, which
I thought looked nice.
But that must suffer from
the same performance
limitations then so.
PAUL IRISH: Probably,
yeah, yeah.
And generally you want to
bring down the number of
render layers that you're
manipulating at the same time,
and keep that to a minimum.
But that was a small
optimization that we found.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: I guess the
page gets caught or painted as
a bitmap as soon as it goes
in through GPU in 3D
transforming.
So if you don't have to redraw
that bit map while it's in
perspective, I assume it's
going to be a lot faster.
PAUL IRISH: So yeah, reveal.js
has been great.
And I particularly like editing
my slides in HTML,
bringing it out, and having
a great interface on it.
And I know a lot of other
people, including Brendan
Eich, creator of JavaScript,
he's used it as framework.
It's pretty rad.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Yeah, that
was pretty amazing.
I was really happy
to see that.
I also watched, what was
that, it was Lisbon JS
conference last week.
And some crazy number of people
were using reveal.js,
like seven or so.
It was a lot of fun.
That's really rewarding.
I think that inspires
me to keep going.
Otherwise most my projects are
fairly short lived right now.
Wrap them up, and placed
them on GitHub and not
touched them again.
But with reveal.js I'm
definitely continuing on
developing and improving
on long term.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, and so
you've actually kind of
evolved the reveal.js scene more
recently with the release
of rvl.io, I guess you would
pronounce it that way.
Pronunciation doesn't really
exist in the internet.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: I tried to get
reveal.io actually spelled
out, but somebody
else took it.
PAUL IRISH: OK, cool.
Do you want to talk about what
the idea behind rvl.io is?
That worked out.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, the
break was perfect.
Hey, what's up.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Oh, that
was a big break.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
PAUL IRISH: You look stark.
Sir, you are stuck
in molasses.
Not rad.
I am the internet, I am
opposed to this word.
I will break for you.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: That was
a very big break.
Can you hear me now?
PAUL IRISH: Yes, can
hear you good now.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Doing good,
my connection not so much.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah,
he's dropped.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
PAUL IRISH: Can I shoot like 20
seconds of each just when
we're done with Hakim, and then
you just throw it on?
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Oh,
I'm back now.
Wow, and my quality
is good now too.
That's weird.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, of all the
things that we've gone
through, those particular demos
would be easy to kind of
merge in later.
There's a lot of sections we
are talking for awhile.
And it would just like--
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
PAUL IRISH: Our conversation
wasn't very specific about
what was happening on screen.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
PAUL IRISH: Great.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: So we're
starting with rvl.io.
PAUL IRISH: Yep.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
PAUL IRISH: So Hakim, tell me
a little bit about rvl.io.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: So rvl.io is
the HTML or the online editing
suite for reveal.js.
Where you don't have to write
plain HTML, which is what
reveal.js is.
Instead, you can come in and
you can write it in WYSIWYG
editor, you see the--
well, you see what you're
going to get exactly.
I'm to build out a bit of, not
a community around it, but a
hosting for your
presentations.
So you don't even need to
download them to present them
elsewhere, you can keep
them online and
present then on the server.
And it was launched three
weeks ago now,
three or four weeks.
It's been under development
for a while though, at
collaboration, actually, with
a friend Hashad from India.
He's doing the service
side work.
And it's gained a pretty good
number of users so far.
It's been like 3,000,
3,500 users in the
first couple of weeks.
Most people are just playing
around with it though.
But I think there's a definite
audience for it.
I've seen a lot of good things
coming out as well.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
I mean, it's really nice.
And it kind of collects a few of
your different experiments.
The Avgrund I saw just
a moment ago.
There's Reveal, and
there's a lot of
other really nice additions.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Yeah, I'm
trying to use my own stuff.
Wherever I can, just to--
if I end up using something
or one of my previously
experiments, then it feels
like I've done
something right I guess.
That's sort of the thinking.
Yeah, so you can save
your presentation.
You publish the presentation, it
will land on the home page.
And popular presentations
will group up there.
Basically level of editing,
but still very much in
development.
This is another project that I
expect to be working on for a
longer time.
Not just something I put out
there and am done with.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, it's
really nice.
So I don't have an
ability to--
so I know that I can author
and Markdown for reveal.js
Rvl.io I guess, because we have
WYSIWYG we don't really
need to edit in Markdown.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: No, I guess
that's the thinking around it,
you wouldn't need it.
But there are some really
important core features which
aren't in it yet.
But I really believe in
releasing it early, putting it
in front of people and seeing
what they do with it, and then
listening to feedback instead of
trying to solve every case
before release it, I guess.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
OK, question, this view right
here, where I can view my
presentations, we have
essentially this thumbnail.
How are we making this here?
HAKIM EL HATTAB:
The thumbnail?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: The thumbnail
is a minified version of the
presentation.
It's just the presentation
itself.
The same markup, same
styles, everything.
And then a scale is applied
to make it tiny.
It's kind of like a
ghetto thumbnail.
PAUL IRISH: 2D transform
scale?
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Yeah,
that's it.
It actually has a little bit of
additional markup in there,
because it doesn't just the
first slide, it has the other
slides as well.
Some optimization to be done.
But it's an easy way to do a
thumbnail instead of having to
do image processing
on the server and
storing all of that.
It makes the server side work
a little bit more likely.
Which I'm always for.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, absolutely.
Great.
And so the last thing I wanted
to talk about, real quick, is
this wonderful project that you
worked on while you were
at Fantasy Interactive.
And this is the 20 Things
I Learned About The Web.
e-book.
It's a book on the web.
But it's like the most book
on the web book there is.
So the experience is very
similar to a real book.
And there's a lot of techniques
in here that people
haven't really seen, especially
outside of Flash before.
So you want to talk a little bit
about how you built this?
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Sure, I think
this came out early 2011.
And I was working out of FI, so
we collaborated with Google
and the Chrome team.
The techniques about--
there's a lot of--
we tried to use everything we
could that was kind of leading
edge at the time.
So we're using, for
instance, local
storage to keep a bookmark.
If you go back to the book after
having visited it once,
and just dropped out at a page,
it will bring you back
into that page again.
We're using offline or cache,
application cache.
Since it's a very large book,
there's many illustrations in
there, it gets pretty
heavy in kilobytes.
So there's a cache manifest,
which stores all that on your
computer for the next time.
And we are using HTML5
History API.
So every page has a unique
URL, and you
can link into that.
The book has been translated
into a bunch of
languages as well.
I guess the most interesting
part, one thing that everybody
asks about is the page flip.
So the page flip is one very big
canvas element on top of
the whole book.
And then that in conjunction
with taking the page, which is
on the right side, and just
shrinking it downwards.
By having the overflow
be hidden, it makes
it look like a mask.
It's basically a magic trick.
The page underneath does just
get covered but the paper
that's coming up on top.
It gets covered, otherwise it
would be a hard cut where the
page is actually being masked.
Instead there's a layer on
top with paper which
makes it look nice.
You pull it over there, and then
there's a lot of shading.
I spent a good amount of time
figuring out the shadows, and
the highlights, and the
paper, and all that to
get that just right.
And we also--
I wrote an article about
that it as well.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, so people
can check this out.
This is on HTML5 rocks.
So if you just look for HTML5
Rocks Page Flip, you should be
able to read this great article
by Hakim, all about
this particular effect, the
markup, the theory, the
science, the math behind it.
And you know, steal the code and
use it on your own site.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: Oh yeah,
definitely steal it.
Steal everything I do.
PAUL IRISH: I like that.
I like it.
Cool.
Yeah, where do you use--
I mean there's a lot of
techniques in this 20 Things I
Learned project, and that
was a while ago.
And you always are staying up to
date with what's available
and browsers.
How do you manage to keeping
track of what's available and
the best way to do things?
HAKIM EL HATTAB: That's
a good question.
I think most of it is I get
really snowed into one
specific feature that I get
super excited about, and I try
to master it.
So for very long period
of time that
was canvas, 2D canvas.
Just drawing all kinds
of animations.
And then recently it's been CSS,
and CSS transports and
transitions, in particular.
I've been using a lot.
I think I stay up to date with
it by seeing something that
excites me, and then just using
100 times over to see
what I can pull of with it.
And then in the end it ends up
being a loop of inspiration, I
guess, because you create
something that inspires
something else.
A good example is what you're
looking at now.
I had no idea what I was doing
when I started this.
This is a good example because
it is one of those cases where
I sat down and I placed a bunch
of dots on the screen.
And then, by doing that, I
started getting inspired into
connecting lights in between the
dots and moving the dots
around physically in a
relationship to each other.
And you start getting visual
effect that's pleasing.
And that's sort of where I land
on something like this.
It's not much planning,
it's mostly duration.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah,
it's very cool.
I especially like--
I mean we saw this a little bit
with Bret Victor getting
immediate feedback ideas.
But there's a lot, especially
inside of the creative JS
realm where you can just start
with an idea and just
experiment until you find
the visual you like, the
interaction style you like.
There's a lot of flexibility
there that you normally don't
have in other parts of front-end
development.
HAKIM EL HATTAB: That's true.
It's also about doing it as a
personal experiment, which
means there's no pressure on
you doing a specific thing.
I think the scary part is having
a specific picture in
mind, and trying to achieve
that exact thing.
Because then you limit yourself
from actually--
I don't know, it's more natural
to come up with the
thing you're doing.
It has to do with, you can never
have a complete picture
and just execute on that idea.
You have to be adaptive
throughout.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, absolutely.
Well there's a lot more
experiments that we could go
through that you've done that,
that are just totally change
at how people look at
experiencing the
front end of the web.
But I guess we'll
cut it there.
Hakim, thank you very
much for joining us.
This has been fantastic
to dive into
some of these products.
And thank you.
People can check you out, your
blog and some of your
experiments at hakim.se.
You're over on Twitter,
@hakimel.
I think, GitHub,
too, @hakimel.
Correct?
HAKIM EL HATTAB:
Yep, that's it.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
And definitely take
a poke around some
of all these projects.
View source pretty much all
of them are on GitHub.
People can go fork them, make
tweaks, and then certainly
make use of some of them
in any upcoming
products, and stuff.
So thanks again, thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]